bienvenidos a este segmento especial
dedicado a la cob 26 desde glasgow
escocia durante estos segmentos
estaremos hablando acerca de las
novedades que salen de esta importante
conferencia sobre el cambio climático y
entrevistando a algunas personalidades y
representantes tanto de la sociedad
civil como de actores gubernamentales y
no estatales conmigo hoy se encuentra
gonzalo muñoz el ex campeón del clima de
la cob 25 gonzalo muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 y lo
primero que quería preguntarte era que
son los campeones del clima y cuál es su
papel muchas gracias me dan gusto estar
con ustedes todos sabemos que en la base
del trabajo que se está haciendo tiene
que ver con el acuerdo de parís el
acuerdo de parís fue este fabuloso logro
al que llegan las naciones del mundo el
año 2015 y en ese acto de llegar a un
acuerdo se reconoce por primera vez de
manera formal que cuando se trata de
implementar ese acuerdo
eso ocurre en los gobiernos
subnacionales que no tienen un espacio
en la sala para firmar el acuerdo y
ocurre muchas veces a través las
acciones concretas que desarrollan
empresas el sector financiero las
universidades entonces se crea una
agenda para movilizar la acción
climática de esos llamados actores no
estatales y es desde entonces que cada
nación que toma la presidencia de la cob
tiene que nombrar a un y una grace jones
high level klammer action champions o
campeón climático para que lidere la
acción climática de voy a simplificar
los gobiernos subnacionales y sector
privado para implementar el acuerdo de
parís aumentar la ambición porque cuando
eso ocurre las naciones lo detectan y
dicen ah ok entonces podemos nosotros
también mejorar las leyes y aumentar
nuestra propia emisión y se activa lo
que se llama el look de ambición eso es
lo que hacemos trabajamos de dos en dos
y por lo tanto en este momento estamos
activos yo como chao champions de las 25
y nadie topping como champions de la cob
26 yo termino mi mandato en el último
día de esta cop y tendrá que ser
nombrado o nombrada alguien de áfrica
para tomar ese rol para la con 27 y
precisamente mencionabas a los gobiernos
subnacionales
cuál es el papel que ellos tienen en la
lucha contra el cambio climático bueno
cuando se trata de los gobiernos
subnacionales nos referimos por un lado
a muchas veces gobiernos estatales no se
refiere el estado de california o el
estado de new jazz vuelo el estado de
sao paulo o la región metropolitana de
chile ellos tienen un rol o la comunidad
autónoma de madrid ellos tienen un rol
de dirigir la acción climática en ese
territorio siempre acondicionado por
supuesto a la legislación nacional
algunos de ellos con mayores con mayores
herramientas que otros pero luego si nos
vamos a logran ular en muchos casos
hablamos de ciudades los alcaldes
alcaldes a los municipios y aunque a
veces incluso los pequeños pueblos en
esos lugares
dependiendo de cuál sea la legislación
muchas veces es la autoridad que define
cuál es el tipo de energía que se usa
cuáles son las normas para el transporte
qué lugares son peatonales y qué lugares
se pueden utilizar con vehículos
particulares o están restringidos a
transporte público y eso tiene un efecto
enorme por supuesto en en las emisiones
de ese territorio después todo lo que
tiene que ver con las normas de
construcción cuando se definen cuáles
son las normas constructivas pero
también las legislación las de
eficiencia energética las zonas verdes
el uso del agua y por supuesto prácticas
tan comunes como el manejo de la basura
y por lo tanto potenciar el reciclaje el
compostaje son todas normas que muchas
veces están en las manos de la autoridad
local e implementadas adecuadamente
sirven para reducir las emisiones de ese
territorio y contribuir al compromiso
que hace el respectivo la respectiva
nación en la cual ellos se encuentran
precisamente hablabas del desperdicio de
comida es bueno dos tercios de la comida
que producimos se echa a perder que
podemos hacer nosotros como ciudadanos
de a pie para evitar que eso suceda hay
múltiples acciones yo creo que es
importante entender que hay una parte de
eso donde los ciudadanos tenemos una
responsabilidad como individuos nosotros
siempre decimos si nosotros si cada
persona si marina hace todo lo perfecto
que hay que hacer para contribuir a la
acción climática y yo también y todos
vamos a resolver más o menos un 20 por
ciento del problema es mucho pero
todavía no es que un 80 por ciento que
está en manos de las autoridades y
autoridades me refiero muchas veces
privadas hay una parte de los residuos
orgánicos que se genera en la fase
productiva en los campos en el
procesamiento de alimentos y luego hay
una parte que tiene que ver con los post
consumo
tenemos que entender primero es que
hemos llegado a un punto en el
desarrollo en la humanidad en que es
inmoral desechar un residuo alimenticio
no sólo por lo que lo que quizás nos
movía mucho en los 80 que nos sigue se
nos debe seguir moviendo que tiene que
ver con el hambre y los lugares donde
hay gente que no tiene para comer no
pero además toda la energía que se gastó
todos los esfuerzos que se hicieron para
llevar ese producto alimenticio hasta un
plato debe hacernos reflexionar en
términos de servir tener un plato lo que
te vas a comer y comerte lo que te
serviste y aquellos restos debemos
evitar que se vayan a un botadero oa un
vertedero o un relleno sanitario porque
en su descomposición generan gases de
efecto invernadero que muchas veces son
más nocivos como en el caso del metano
iba a decir perdón por por interrumpir
finalmente me querían nos queda poquito
tiempo entonces quería ver si nos podían
dar un adelanto de algunos de los
anuncios que vamos a poder ver durante
esta con 26 muy brevemente en esta cop
vamos a ver el resumen del trabajo que
hemos hecho durante los últimos dos años
en mi caso 3 porque empecé en el último
día de kato dice fundamentalmente en
tres campañas race to siglos la carrera
hacia el cero donde vamos a tener un
anuncio extraordinario de cuántas
empresas cuántas ciudades cuántas
regiones cuántos inversionistas
universidades centros de salud se han
sumado a un compromiso de seguir la
ciencia y hacer ese compromiso formar
frente la nación a unidad el número es
un número realmente sorprendente sobre
todo si miramos que hace tres años atrás
ese número era cero hace tres años atrás
no teníamos un formato una metodología
para que el sector privado y los
gobiernos nacionales se comprometieran a
justamente acompañar la ciencia en la
trayectoria hacia las cero emisiones
netas y la ruta a los 1,5 grados lo
mismo está ocurriendo con el sector
financiero hoy en día la cantidad de
bancos la cantidad de inversionistas que
han decidido tomar esta trayectoria es
sorprendente y yo invito a la prensa
aquí para que diseñe la curva dibujen la
marca en los puntos donde estábamos hace
tres años tratos estábamos hace un año
atrás y donde estamos hoy y lo mismo en
la carrera será resiliencia en rise to
brazil ians es sorprendente porque eso
da a entender que estamos en un momento
donde no podemos permitirnos que
solamente sean las naciones las que
toman las decisiones y guían qué es lo
que debemos hacer todos a nivel
individual y el nivel colectivo y a
nivel organizacional tenemos un deber
que cumplir
ustedes como un medio de comunicación
deben hacerlo también a través de lo que
comunican pero también a través de las
emisiones del propio canal